one of the beautiful things about the
Internet is that everybody has a voice
one of the terrible things about the
internet said everybody has a voice and
a lot of people don't have anything
worth listening to that they say and so
sifting through that and finding a way
to determine the signal out of all that
noise is one of the challenges of our
time it's part of the hallmark of
shifting from an economy and an ecology
of scarcity to one of abundance you look
at a grocery store in the u.s. right
that is a fantastical concept to someone
from 50 years ago and prior in human
existence it's still a fantastical
concept of people from developing
nations you go to a star market or
Walgreens or giant foods or whole foods
or what have you how many choices of
cereal do we need we've got like 80
choices of cereal diet cereal choco
choco Krispie nutty cereal cereal with
oxytocin's innum cereal with herbs and
whatnot we infuse cereal probably vodka
and bacon infused cocoa pebbles like
it's getting a bit nuts and so what that
industry has done its kind of thrown a
lot of money at marketing and pay for
positioning in the store and trying to
convince you that like this cereal is
worth more than that cereal and that's
that's part of the solution but the real
thing is to a don't feel as a as a
reader as a digester as a downloader of
this vast world of abundance you don't
have to feel obligated to read it all
you don't have to try to know everything
or watch everything they're way too many
things just like there's too many cereal
choices in the grocery store there's so
many videos on YouTube to watch them all
and if you're someone who's pushing
stuff out there you don't have to read
all the comments either in fact I advise
you heavily not to read all the comments
brand is important community is
important in a sea of dramatic change
we're up is down and this is the
situation a day and that's the situation
tomorrow people cling to beliefs they
cling to a community they cling to names
and brands and places that they trust
and Trust is important in this world and
so
if you're in the business of producing
content and information and trying to
grab people's attention the mere act of
producing it is not special oh great
your photographer you take pictures so
do I so does everybody with the camera
phone that's no longer special building
community around that is a little more
special building a special sensibility
and brand and sort of signature and
hallmark is special so you look at I
don't know mcsweeney's as as a as a
literary brand that has live events and
a highly tactile experience with some of
their printed products and a design
aesthetic that signals to a community
this is what we are we're more than just
words on a page or on a screen we are an
intentional community we are a
perspective on the world and the more
you send out more than raw data and
information but actual intention and
sensibility and perspective the more
people will self identify and find that
especially if you give them chances to
also feel like they're a part of that as
well because you're not special just
because you can make things like it's
very important people to realize that
everybody can make things so what else
can you build beyond the raw thing
beyond the bits that you publish
you